[Music]
Donald Trump jr. kg they want on the
view today to promote his brand new book
triggered which also happens to describe
the scene surrounding his appearance
with the ladies of the view take a look
lowering the discourse to his level
which is horrible for this country even
if people are working we don't want to
have a country like that I mean if we're
talking about bringing a discourse down
joy
you've worn blackface whoopee Lansky it
wasn't rape rape when he raped a child
joining us now all through the new book
triggered he's in Birmingham tonight the
president's son executive vice president
of the Trump Organization Donald Trump
jr. you got to tell everybody Hannity
says hello
Hannity says hello guys
Shawn I'm watching this thing today and
I'm like why why did you even bother why
you know what every once in a while you
get a try you got to try to speak to
everyone hopefully they listen in that
case they didn't cuz you would think if
you're invited on the show and they
build it up and they're giving you three
segments you'd think if you were there
to promote a book they'd ask you one
question about the actual book Shawn but
they didn't do that so I guess it's a
little bit about why I wrote triggered I
think the title speaks for itself
because they were obviously triggered I
don't think they like me much anymore I
listen I used to do all those stupid
shows I think the last time I went on
that show
Rosie O'Donnell was hosting and lost her
mind and poor Barbara Walters couldn't
control the chaos you know but the
reality is look at this whole media
thing okay
there's a quid pro quo there's no quid
pro quo your father is faithfully
executing the laws but there was a quid
pro quo and that's Joe who knew his son
was being investigated you fire the
prosecutor you get a billion you don't
fire the prosecutor you don't get a
billion quid pro quo Joe Don yeah in its
own tape in front of everyone and he's
saying it that way there's no ambiguity
there's no nothing he was in control of
it hunter Biden's getting boards of
companies and languages he can't speak
and companies he knows nothing about why
are you there hunter
oh I never really thought about that
well I know why you're there I think
everyone in America knows why you're
there
and so we're having a good time here at
books-a-million in Birmingham Alabama
Sean doing a little bit of the triggered
tour but uh glad we could get these guys
in there because I think they're all in
agreement with us you know by the way I
started I had 90 miles north of
Birmingham I was broadcasting in
Huntsville Alabama at a great two years
there in the newspaper wrote an
editorial when I left goodbye to the
talk-show hosts from hell I was very
proud of that but I will say this that
sounds like my average day showing is
that yeah I think we're in the same boat
the thing is it you know if a kid we're
at a maggot results in what they did to
Nicholas Sandman and look why besmirched
meant that libel the slander the smears
I don't think there's any low they won't
stop I think the next 362 days it is
gonna be a war every day to destroy you
your family your dad with lice because
they've been lying now for three years
well that's exactly right and I mean you
saw what happened to me yesterday I
literally retweeted an article with the
name of the supposed whistleblower in
the title of the article and there's
outrage Donald Jr outs whistleblower I
go like it was on Drudge four days ago
it's in Real Clear Politics it was in
Breitbart it was in you know a couple
other places like record ever and I'm
like what's the app he's in danger of
his life I'm like this is a CIA
operative in danger of his life I wish
they would have shown a little bit of
the same amount of outrage when my
family opened up a white powder
substance in an exploding envelope they
showed up at my house these guys are
full of it Sean and the thing is they're
not outraged that he was outed they're
outraged that now that his name is out
there everyone's able to realize this is
a guy that's tied to Brennan this is a
guy that's tied to Susan Rice this is a
guy that worked for Biden with the
Ukraine nonsense and this is a guy whose
lawyer has been tweeting since January
of 17 the coup has started impeachment
is next we're gonna get Trump out of
there this is just a joke and they
realize they got caught in the act again
because they wanted this innocent public
servant whistleblower who's doing the
right thing instead of just another one
of the coup Cabal of those Klan
they've been doing this for three years
and the reality is the American public
gets it Sean they see through this
nonsense they're sick of it as I am and
they should be because if it's going on
here in America in 2019 we should all be
ashamed of ourselves that they're trying
to overthrow a duly elected president
because they didn't get the results that
they wanted and they want to promote
their socialist leftist policies and
that's the only thing that matters
that's disgusting if this was going on
in a banana republic Sean
we'd be outraged it's going on here in
America right now all right Don jr. we
wish you the best send my my love call
my friends in Birmingham and you got you
got to get they have some of the best
barbecue you got you got to stop at one
of the places Don thank you good luck on
your book tour